comment expliquer cette montée de
tension deux invités will prosper
documentariste mais les temps pour les
droits humains et ancien policier de la
grc bonsoir vous le pouvez super bien
venu d'inde morin co directeur de
l'observatoire sur la radicalisation et
l'extrémisme violent et directeur de la
sécurité de l'observatoire sur les
politiques publiques de l'université
sherbrooke
bonsoir david morin mais d'abord on va
regarder quelques images qui sont
explicites qui sont dérangeantes on va
démontrer qu'une seule fois des images
filmées lors de la manifestation où il
ya eu deux morts et où un suspect un
jeune homme de 17 ans appartenant
semble-t-il à des groupes pour adhérents
à la thèse des suprémacistes blancs
étaient venus porter secours aidées
devraient agir les forces policières en
place avaient répondu à l'appel de
patriote on va regarder
il ya eu beaucoup de coups de feu il ya
eu en fait les contre-manifestants la
ccc milices se promène dans les rues
armés jusqu'aux dents et le tireur
aurait fait un premier une première
victime atteinte à la tête
et puis ensuite il ce tireur est
pourchassé par les manifestants on le
voit un moment donné tombé au sol
ils tirent sur des manifestants qui
tentent de le rattraper fait d'autre
blessé et il se relève et se dirige
finalement en direction des voitures de
police vous allez voir les verts sont
allés puis va mettre les bras en l'air
mais y était remis de sa r15 de dons son
fusil semi automatique puis on voit que
vous allez voir qu'on voit que les
policiers qui passaient à côté de lui le
laisse partir sans être importuné du
tout du tout et cnn vous le voyez là il
passe à côté des policiers pour le
laisser partir alors que des gens qui le
pourchassent et qui lui qui disait que
c'est lui qui a tiré et dans l'autre
moment de la soirée c'est pas précise
c'est avant ou après cette séquence là
on voit des
des jeunes mulet qui sont qu'échangent
avec les policiers qui sont dans leur
gros camions et les policiers les
remercie d'être là de les aider et leur
fait même des bouteilles d'eau qu'on
entend dire c'est un tube gaz
merci merci d'être là les gars alors on
va s'interroger sur la signification de
tout ça avec david morin p will prosper
d'abord vous il prospère quand vous
regardez ces images et que vous voyez la
situation que l'on tente de récupérer
des deux côtés entre la classe politique
démocrate et républicain qu'est ce que
vous en fait c'est profondément
inquiétant la division qui s'opèrent se
disent on est tous qui se poursuit en
fait depuis déjà des c'est qu'on
pourrait dire il ya une partie qui
demandent justice sociale puis une
partie qui est ce que vantent de thor
auprès de la population et j'ai
l'impression que les gens sont de plus
en plus braqués chacun leur côté c'est
une véritable poudrière conte a
démissionné il ya des gens qui sont
battus pour le droit de porter des armes
librement dans la rue et on voit la
police qui supportent ce type de
mouvements là et on voit une personne de
17 ans qui s'en prend à des manifestants
selon ce que lui juge lui-même comme
étant un acte de désobéissance civile et
il va y aller à ce point d'exécuter des
gens et la prise d'entrée en avait déjà
parlé de nous donc il faut mettre des
actions contre es tu es et ce qui est
plus frappant en fait c'est de voir que
monsieur blake qui lui n'a pas d'armes
rentrer dans son véhicule et est qu'il
menace pour les policiers même s'il n'a
absolument rien et maintenant on voit un
jeune homme qui vient de tuer deux
personnes qui est armé et on le traite
comme un roi
et ça si ces images ne sont pas assez
marquante je ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'il
faut pour montrer ce serait presque oui
je suis assez d'accord avec ce que dit
monsieur prospère ça confirme levier
implicite qui existe dans une partie de
la culture policière américaine
c'est pas tous les corps de police c'est
pas tous les policiers mais clairement
écouter en plein
mouvement social black nice matin les
quelques derniers jours viennent
viennent confirmer finalement les
raisons pour lesquelles les afro
américains réclament aujourd'hui un
changement de culture au niveau de la
niveau de la police donc je pense que ça
ça fait pas de ça fait pas de doute dans
mon esprit les images parlent d'elles
mêmes ce qui moi me surprend un peu si
vous voulez c'est la complaisance à des
corps policiers qu'on voit la dent
encore une fois c'est pas forcément tous
les corps policiers mais de cela à
l'égard d'hommes qui sont armés
et si les images des policiers qui donne
de l'eau par exemple précède le crime
qui a été commis par le jeune homme on
voit que a priori ça avait peut-être
dépassé l'heure du couvre-feu a priori
c'est un homme de 17 ans je suis pas
convaincu que ce soit légal de porter
une arme ouvertement quand on a 17 ans
dans cette dans cette ville a donc
peut-être que si les policiers avaient
bien fait leur travail à ce moment là
ils l'avaient contrôlé ben ça serait pas
ça serait pas arrivé donc on voit
finalement un enchaînement d'événements
marqué par ce biais implicite à
l'endroit des miliciens qui a conduit au
drame qu'on dénonce aujourd'hui en voie
de traitement
vous l'avez souligné david
et vous le prospère c'est que un homme
blanc armés jusqu'aux dents avec d'une
arme semi automatique peut déambuler
c'est son droit constitutionnel en fait
ils fameux deuxième amendement que
réclame le beaucoup d'américains en
revanche un noir non armé de dos peut se
faire tirer parce qu'on soupçonne qu'il
a peut-être pris les clés de la maison
d'où qu'ils devaient pas vendre ces
mêmes puisqu'elle va peut-être un
couteau dans la voiture est ce que est
ce un moule prospère est ce qu'on
comment on peut tirer les leçons de
cette de cette histoire mais je pense
justement les leçons de tout lui les
tirs et malheureusement parce qu'on est
rendu à un point où est ce que si on
retourne peu dans une sorte qu'ils aient
pas si lointaine en 2012 on parlait de
tout événement et jo jo zimmermann donc
c'est quelqu'un qui s'est auto déclarée
patrouilleurs qui commençaient à
circuler dans les rues et qui a abattu
un jeune qui était dans cette rue là
aussi derrière moi et bien jagger la
même chose est arrivée on pense aux
incidents à charleston où est ce que ce
jeune là et à des pères une fusillade
dans une église de noir et la police a
amené ce jeune là avec un traitement
royal pour rechercher des brevets et je
vous rappelle que je parle de ce cas de
zimmerman mais c'est un système
judiciaire qui ne l'a pas reconnu
coupable donc on se ramasse a à dire des
messages blake lively on se commence à
demander des actions policières
et quelle leçon à tirer c'est une
excellente question parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on ne tire pas de leçon
et non pas d'action sort surtout et les
milices david morin êtes un expert de
ces choses-là ce jeune homme adhérait
donc à la cause de trump été vu dans des
allées voulait protéger voulait contrer
les manifestations qui sèment le chaos
mais ces milices elles servent à qui à
quoi
avec quelles conséquences oui alors ce
que on parle souvent du second
amendement puisque beaucoup de gens ne
savent pas en fait c'est que le second
amendement qui donc reconnaît au peuple
américain le droit de porter des armes
est justifiée par le fait est là je cite
la constitution que une milice bien
organisée et nécessaire pour la sécurité
d'un état libre donc au départ le
deuxième amendement finalement il est
fait pour reconnaître le droit à des
groupes organisés éventuellement d'avoir
des armes contre un état qui
viendrait totalitaire qui essaieraient
de les désarmer en mettant une armée
fédérale
et ce qui est important là dedans c'est
que en fait il ya eu un glissement et ça
fait toujours débat aux états unis vers
le fait que le droit collectif de porter
des armes ou de certains groupes s'est
tranquillement transformé en fait en un
droit d'auto défense individuelle et le
législateur américain progressivement y
compris la cour suprême ont reconnu ça
comme un droit individuel mais il ya
encore beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui aux
états unis qui conteste sa entend dans
la constitution la façon dont les pères
fondateurs le voyez c'était vraiment un
regroupement collectif alors les milices
ça a une longue histoire aux états unis
il y en a eu beaucoup et un gros
développement au début des années 90 on
se souvient notamment de la tacc de waco
on se souvient aussi de timothy mcveigh
l'attentât en 1995 à oklahoma city qui
finalement était un peu l'apogée puisque
on les reconnaissait des liens avec des
milices ca a baissé dans les années qui
ont suivi jusqu'au au milieu des années
2000 et l'élection d'obama est en fait
l'élection d'obama a vraiment contribué
à relancer les groupes de milices aux
états unis qui ont monté augmenter
encore dans les dernières années donc
peut-être pour que les gens clarifiée il
ya deux types de milice il ya ceux qui
sont vraiment pour défendre les liberté
plutôt anti gouvernementaux donc ils
sont très proches des libertés publiques
etc
il ya des ministres qui sont plus un peu
survivalistes post apocalyptique et qui
se prépare finalement au cas où il y
aurait un désastre naturel
l'effondrement du monde une guerre
civile etc et maintenant à l'heure
actuelle on voit que l'extrême droite a
récupéré certains mouvements et
notamment il y avait à thomas von
division qui est carrément une
organisation milicienne terroristes aux
états unis qui a commis des attaques et
des attentats donc si vous voulez
aujourd'hui on est face à une situation
et je rejoins en partie ce que disait
monsieur prospère où la situation est
devenue un peu incontrôlable il ya des
grosses polarisation l'est où des gens
en groupe ou individuellement se sentent
finalement le droit de prendre des armes
pour aller dire nous mêmes on va
finalement défendre l'état mais avec des
contradictions que souvent ils sont
aussi contre l'état et là ils savent pas
trop comment situez parce que souvent
ils appuient quand même donald trump et
donc ça ils sont dans une position
inconfortable normalement ils sont
contre le gouvernement américain mel à
la tête du gouvernement américain
il ya quelqu'un qui soutiennent et donc
on voit quand même le genre de drame ou
quelle sauce on va te le fais là dessus
david morin will prosper